okay so we're going to look at a
sequence of numbers and it's not going
to be this one which is where i start
with a one and then for no obviously
explained reason another one and then i
feel the need to add them together which
gives me a two if i add the last two
terms together i get a three if i add
those together i get a five i get an
eight and so on and most people will
recognize these as our friends the
fibonacci numbers and they're famous for
a number of reasons
in fact right brady do you know why
why do people get so excited about these
numbers i mean you've talked to many
people i imagine over the years because
of sunflowers because of sunflowers yes
or pineapples or
petals and so yes often things in nature
occur in numbers and some of those
numbers are in this list
the other big one and and people or
almost take fibonacci to be synonymous
with this is the golden ratio and people
would will switch between saying
fibonacci numbers golden ratio and i
think it's time
we stop doing that i'm here to tell you
that the fibonacci numbers are terrible
and they have very little to do with the
golden ratio in fact there's a much
better sequence of numbers which we
should use instead of fibonacci when it
comes to the golden ratio but first
we'll establish what we're making fun of
before we tear it apart so the reason we
like fibonacci numbers linking to the
golden ratio is if you take the ratio of
two of the terms so the last one here
i've got is 34.
i take the ratio of 34 with 21. so if i
do 34 divided by 21 it equals 1.6190
so it's close and so these terms
approach
the ratio of the golden ratio if i kept
writing these numbers so if i carried on
and you know let's say i don't know how
much you know space you've got on your
camera if we did this for two maybe
three years
the numbers would be closer and closer
to the golden ratio and the limit
they're approaching is the golden ratio
so never reach it but if you do this for
infinitely many terms in the fibonacci
sequence the ratio is the golden ratio
here's a lovely link the trouble is it's
the fibonacci sequence is not the only
one that does this so in fact we're
going to try another one entirely at
random so uh can you give me brady the
two so instead of starting one one can
you give me a number with let's say in
the thousands four digits what would you
like
two thousand two thousand three hundred
eight three hundred and eight and
another number four thousand
two hundred and sixty one okay so
there's our two random numbers you've
got two thousand three hundred and eight
and you've got four thousand two hundred
and sixty one so instead of starting one
one and adding those to get two i'm
going to start 2308 second term will be
4261. the next term will be 6000 also
going to be
and then the next term i'm going to
cheat and if i start using a calculator
if i add these up be ten thousand eight
three zero
forty five thousand six hundred and
twenty so i'll do it for a few of these
and you can zip through it obviously so
is this the brady segment thousand two
two this is the brady sequence so these
are we're gonna call these the brady
numbers
and so as we go down i'm generating
you've got your very am i the first
person who's giving you your own numbers
is this going to get on that i find this
this would be in the online encyclopedia
of integer sequences i guarantee you
someone will put the brady sequence up
and there's not even a matte sequence
which i find hugely offensive so he's
getting big should we go until we get
just past a million let's do that okay
so let's stop there one million three
hundred and twenty five thousand one
hundred and sixty
five that's the lowest seven digit brady
number that is that is the first seven
digit brady number so now we've got this
list of the brady numbers shall we see i
mean the fibonacci numbers they have
five is their ratio should we see what
the brady numbers have okay so we start
with the last one here one three two
five one six five divided by the one
before it so this is the ratio i'm doing
the ratio of these two here divided by
eight
one eight
nine nine six equals
1.6180359
and the golden ratio
is
1.6180339
so on right
so
the ratio of the brady numbers oh how
many have i done i've you started with
two so this let's even count those one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven twelve thirteen the 14th when
we got to the 14th brady number and look
how many decimal places it matches the
golden ratio it's because
i mean i don't want to say it's not
because the body numbers are special
because obviously they are but on top of
that it works for any sequence if you
start any sequence where you add the two
previous terms to get the next term you
will always approach the golden ratio so
it's not just fibonacci it's any
sequence whatsoever that you come across
and uh we can prove that
what letter would you like brady for for
either any any greek letter do you have
a favorite uh
delta delta